[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar an approach to ultra sensitive
detection and quantification of copy
number variations cnvs and mutations
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by new probe to learn more visit
newprobe.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speakers dr
nicholas garrod
director of business development at new
probe and dr jenny zhang associate
director of innovation at new probe
dr garo de la brez dr zhang you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for your introduction hello
everyone welcome and thank you for
joining in your previous webinar trust
entity detection and quantification of
copy number operations
and mutations
before we get started just a reminder
that the following products and services
are for research use only and not for
diagnostic procedures
so today's learning objectives include
identifying the main challenges of
current methods for sensitive cnp
detection
using how new props qa6 technology can
increase sensitivity of both cnv and
mutation detections
from tissue and liquid biopsy samples
demonstrating the development and
validation of a custom qrsic panel for
the simultaneous and ultrasonic
detection of cnv's and mutations in the
erbb2 genes as well as other genes
and providing an overview of custom
asset development and validation
services for biopharma and research
applications
here's an outlines of today's
presentation please note that we'll not
be taking all your questions during the
webinar if you like to submit a question
do do so through the
q a or chat feature and please feel free
to submit questions at any time and
questions will be answered
during the trip
after the webinar
i will now introduce a new probe
so you probably say genomics and
molecular diagnostic
companies developing novel research and
diagnostic tools to improve the
detection of nucleic acid biomarkers in
cancer from tissue and liquid biopsy
samples
building on a portfolio of technologies
including proprietary pcr chemistry
ngs library preparation primary design
and data analysis software
newport provides a range of solutions to
biopharma companies and diagnostic
companies through asset development
sample testing and kit manufacturing
services
here is a selection of recent
partnerships between new problem leading
companies in life sciences and
diagnostics using new props technologies
across different platforms including
next generation sequencing
pcr nanopore sequencing
and different applications and disease
areas
i will now let genie introduce the qs6
technology developed by newpro
um good morning everyone i'm jenny jenn
currently working at new probe as the
associate director of innovation it is
my pleasure to introduce our acuity
technology to you guys
first let's start with some general
background in dna in
oncology dna biomarkers are well known
for its clinical relevance to cancer
diagnosis and treatment monitoring among
the stinging variants there are three
different categories
single nucleotide variants short
insertion and deletions and structural
variations
in this webinar we'll be focusing on
introducing our question technology that
is targeting at accurate cnv detections
why cmv is so important from this figure
we can see a broad existence of cnv
among all these cancer types and the
high alteration frequency in some
specific cancer types like prostate
cancer and breast cancer
detecting this assuming biomarkers can
contribute greatly to prognosis and
therapeutics
therefore we would like to proudly
introduce our question technology which
is a highly multiplexed pcr based
targeting enrichment ngs panel that can
offer accuracy detection and
quantitation on molecular level on
multiple cma genes simultaneously
cma's importance is getting more and
more attention in this industry and
people have developed multiple
technologies to quantify popular tme
genes
so what is the uniqueness of our
heuristic technology
first of all nds panels comparing to
ddpcr fish or
immunohistochemistry has its obvious
advantages
there are theoretically speaking ngs
panels do not have the limitation on
multiplexing like dd pcr and fish
because they are limited in the
selection of fluorescence channels
another advantage is that ngs can detect
mutations and cnvs simultaneously which
can offer more genetic information when
patient sample is limited or hard to
obtain in large amount
also there is a rising attention of
cell-free dna in oncology for early
cancer screening non-invasive neural
therapy selection and post treatment
monitoring
where fish and ihc is not applicable and
ddpcr are not sufficient for screening
purposes
in spite of all the advantages mentioned
above about ngs panels
cards and js panels on the market are
difficult to detect sensitively using
high throughput sequencing with a limit
of only 25 percent heterozygous single
copy variation
there are two reasons that many
contributing to the bottleneck of ngs
panels
first is actual
is the exponential increased
difficulty in hiding multiplex pcr
primer designs
second is a low utility rate of the
input dna samples
i will dive into this two point in the
next several slides
first we developed a stochastic stepwise
pcr primer design algorithm that can
design high specific highly specific
primers while keeping the orthogonality
of primers to reduce timer formation on
each one of the pcr steps
in the middle figure we evaluated primer
designs using the internal balance
function
and three sets are picked to demonstrate
algorithm performance
in this 100 plus primer designs of
primer design set number one two and
three
we can see that the more optimization
involved the lower band score will lead
to a higher on target rate
with this algorithm we increase the on
target rate from 10 percent to 70
percent which will benefit in both
sequencing cost and even higher
multiplexed ngs panel designs
the second innovation of qe-6 is our
high-efficiency molecule tagging
technology
in the side figure you can find that the
average conversion yield per target in
our panel is around 60
which is three times higher comparing to
traditional nds panels that are using
ligation based method
the high conversion yield is beneficial
in two points
we can achieve much higher sensitivity
to five percent heterozygous single copy
variation or we can either use less
input amount than other panels for
example as low as 5 nanogram input but
achieving the same equivalent
performance in qsix
in cne detection accuracy
on the right figure we can see that the
ploidy poisson distribution is much
wider when considering only 20
conversion yield of the input samples
higher conversion yield can be a
concentrated can concentrate the poisson
distribution to the observed ploidy
and the concentration of the randomness
can be statistically enhanced by
involving as many amplicon as you want
when combining these two normal
technologies in qac which are able to
better balance out the risk randomness
caused by ligation or pcr amplification
accomplishing a limit of detection of
five percent heterozygote single copy
variation
we currently have an internal panel
built around breast cancer which
contains 226 amplicons in solar
targeting at 18 zlin genes and 84
hotspots in 14
genes we first performed a series of
experiments using synthetic reference
materials to determine the analytical
limit of detection for cnvs and
mutations we can see that in the left
figure there is a distinctive difference
between 2.00 ploid in normal sample and
the 2.05 quality sample with the spike
in
in the right figure we can we have
successfully detected mutations and
indels down to 0.2 percent vf using
horizon cell free a sample standard
we also compared our panel performance
with other cme detection methods the ihc
and ddpcr we cross compared 18 fresh
frozen breast cancer samples on the
erbb2 gene for all three methods
on the left figure is a comparison of
ihc and qa6 test results
we are highly aligned with ihc except
for 1 out of 18 samples that ihc defined
as positive while qe6 defined as 2.80
the same outlier showed the same
fluidity when testing in ddpcr as the
red dot shown in the right figure at the
bottom left
our results are consistent with ddpcr on
this sample showing true polity in both
method
we suspect that there is no dna
alteration with this specific sample on
the dna level but there may be a
downstream irregular translation or
protein synthesis that actually give the
positive signaling ihc
in the right figure the vertical blue
bar present represents the lod of uic
and the horizontal gray bar is for the
limited detection for ddpcr
as the comparison between dd-pcr and ihc
we can see that there are noticeable igc
negative samples that are called
positive gain by ddpcr while there is
none in qezek
therefore we demonstrated a much better
concordance with ihc comparing to ddpcr
we tested our panel on tumor and healthy
fresh frozen samples the comparison
between healthy and patient samples is
very distinctive all healthy patient
samples are very stable and close to
tooth quality we also get seven cmv
gains and two cme loss costs on the her2
gene within this patient samples
the right figures summarize the mutation
calls that we got from patient samples
simultaneously we can see that the qec
can capture mutations down to 0.2
percent vf
with the always as little as 5 to 8
nanogram input
as a summary of all fresh frozen samples
tested we found 44 of the samples showed
a lower level of cnv
and that is the only captured by qac
showed in green
this result demonstrated our
capabilities in earlier cnv detections
that are missing by other methods
finally here are some results obtained
from additional clinical samples from
the collaborators at md anderson cancer
center yale school of medicine and
myoclinic
in this experiment we use dna input
between
2.4.4 nanogram and 8.3 nanogram
from the same exact
fsp tissue section we can detect both
cmvs as well as mutations we detect many
dna gains analysis including low levels
in these which is visible here in light
blue and light wrap
we also
we were we were also able to apply the
same exact panel to cell 3 dna
reporting both cnv and mutations of the
same samples
note that
this ffpe and self-reading samples are
now matched samples from the same
patient
this result demonstrates that our qistic
pipeline is highly adaptive to different
sample types
thank you all for your attention on the
qasiq technology i will pass this back
to nicholas and he can provide more
information on biopharma services
thank you deanie for the overview of the
qs6 technologies and now present no
services that newport offers to access
the qs6 technology and supports
transitional research programs
so building on key features of the qasiq
platform we launch an array of services
to develop and validate custom qasiq
panels
so our goal is to support transitional
research and early clinical development
programs with a unique solution to
detect
low level copy number variations such as
amplifications and divisions
together with mutations from tissue and
liquid biopsy samples
our assay development services leverage
the qatic technology that gini just
presented and the expertise of the
services team to build ultra-sensitive
qasiq panels in record time
so here's a summary of key features and
benefits offered by qasiq panels
so qs6 panels provide ultra high
sensitivity for mutation and especially
copy number variations with up to
10-fold improvement over other
technologies such as digital pcr
low input requirements with as low as 5
nanogram of input dna
a flexible solution to integrate a wide
range of biomarkers not just limited to
copy number variations but also
including mutations in theirs
and the compatibility with cell-free dna
for non-invasive testing in addition to
tissue samples so it typically takes
about 12 weeks from the initial assay
specifications
to a ready-to-use custom panel
every project starts with a first
project consultation involving our r d
service team to redefine the required
panel specifications
including the targets of interest being
a series of hotspots
exams of genes with the ability to cover
the entire coding sequence
a sample type such as tissue blood or
self-reading samples and finally finally
the alterations being copy number
provisions mutations in delt or just one
of them
we then proceed with no panel
development and validation
using proprietary design algorithm
chemistry and bioinformatics software
and in terms of deliverables newport
provides two options the first one is
the sample testing and analytics
services performed in our laboratory in
houston or at the new prop certified cro
or clean app
and the second option is the kit
manufacturing services to turn the
custom qsik panel into a standalone
off-the-shelf ngs kit for use across
multiple sites
so here's an overview of the panel
development and validation process using
qac
let's see it is divided in two modules
panel development and analytical
validation
during the first module our service team
designs and optimizes the custom
heuristic panel until we reach
high on cycle rates then the panel and
the protocol are locked and we perform a
series of analytical validation studies
using reference materials from
commercial vendors or prepared by new
prop in order to determine the assay
sensitivity and specificity and
demonstrate repeatability and
reproducibility
once this process is completed essay can
be used for sample testing as a service
or manufacturer into a standalone kit
so for sample testing and analysis there
are two
options the first option is that we
provide the testing services using
custom qa6 panels developed by newport
in our houston network tray so the
turnaround time is one week from sample
delivery to report and the entire
analysis is performing in news time the
second option we provide solutions to
transfer and validate custom panels to
third-party cro partners certified by
newport for clinical trials development
in the u.s and in europe
alternatively the new province offers
the kit manufacturing services to
produce ready-made qhc kits for the
rapid development across multiple sites
and the new prop team has an extensive
experience in manufacturing
ngs and pcr kits including
bioinformatics software development
we offer oem and wide level solutions as
well as packaging storage and shipping
logistics
and that brings me to the end of the
webinar so here's a summary of today's
presentation so we highlighted the
importance of copy number operations in
cancer and the benefits of ngs for
detecting copy number variations
we introduced the heuristic technology a
new ngs method that has been developed
by newport for highly sensitive cmv
detection applicable to both tissue and
liquid biopsy samples
specifically
qhd incorporates novel approaches to
increase the conversion yield increase
multiplexing and reduce error bars to
provide unparalleled cnb detection
accuracy
basic has been validated on panels
designed to detect both tmvs and smd
alterations
mqsiq is available as a custom assay
with sample testing services accessible
through new pro or cro partner or as an
off-the-shelf kit
thank you everyone for attending this
webinar please feel free to ask us
questions during using the live platform
you can also visit our website and
social media accounts to learn more
about new problem state form thank you
thank you dr guerrero de la brez dr
zhang for your informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
for
dr guerrero
how many genes can be covered by a
custom qa sick panel
so typically we can develop and validate
you know custom qa stick panel for the
detection of cn vision hotspot mutations
in up to 30 genes within 12 weeks
so with uh
now a larger panel is feasible but
likely will take more time to develop
thank you
um our next question is again for dr
garreau
could you comment on how custom qac
panels are transferred to cro or clia
laboratories
so in this case though um once the
custom qrsic panel is developed and
validated so the isa is transferred to a
manufacturing team
where our research use only kit
is manufactured in the kit can then be
transferred to a crop a laboratory
partner so we have several partnerships
with ceos in the u.s in europe where we
can walk with your preferred laboratory
thank you
our next question is for dr zhang
how many amplicons are needed to get the
limit of detection and can you do more
amplicons to make it even better
yeah so the current panel that we're
using is around 50 amplicons for one
genes to get the detection limit of
a 0.5
header jacket single copy variation
um but
i mean theoretically speaking you can do
more amplicon but the more noise of the
pcr and the sequencing sequencing errors
will not really benefit on introducing
more amplicons because after that the
the error will be coming instead of from
the panel itself will be something else
so i would say probably 50 will be a
good point to start and uh if we have
better platform we can do do more
thank you
next question is for dr zhang
does qac have any other advantages
comparing to other detection methods
yeah so the advantage that we have been
emphasizing this webinar is focusing on
the dna detection cost
so um
but we have a more
advanced technology with the molecular
tagging so that actually can reduce the
background noise which actually gives
you a higher sensitivity so this same
technology is
the core also applied to the qa6 that
can benefit both on the cnv calls and
the variance cost
thank you
our next question is for dr
for the kit manufacturing option does
new probe provide the bioinformatic
analysis software as part of the kit
oh yeah for each custom uic kit includes
a bioinformatic energy software together
with the
reagents required now for the ngs
library preparation and so the the
bioinformatics
analysis software with technology will
generate a summary report of key
findings in the sample
tested using this the panel and the
input would be a fast queue of data
generated from the sequencing run
thank you
our next question
is a
three-part question
can qac be used to detect cnvs between
homologous blocks within a human
chromosome
what is the highest homology that your
panel can detect between and how does
your technology compare to mlpa
janine would you like to answer this
question
um
yeah so
[Music]
um so
honestly speaking um we didn't actually
have the idea about our technology
comparison to mlpa
um
[Music]
and actually i got a little bit confused
about what do you mean by homology that
your panel tends to tap between so
um
do you mind that we answer a question
like after the seminar like we can do
some deeper research on this specific
question
yes of course um all of these questions
you can direct to the
attendee through their email
and this happens often where there are
questions that are really complicated
and require elaborate responses
and so yes you will be able to answer
the their question via email
our next question is are cnvs measured
across the whole sample
if yes
then what is the effect of contaminating
normal cells on the cnv limit of
detection
cmv
so actually for ngs panels whenever you
do a
panel basically we don't pick the sample
to be input so yes we are measuring
across the whole sample as long as you
have the molecule for the targetable
scenery like the primers they will be
detected
and the cnv limit of detection is based
on the sample level not by uh like uh
so it will be impacted by your tumor
percentage and how many percentage of
the normal cells you can have
so it it's kind of
uh the sample
uh quality before you actually input
into our panel
so what we actually give out is the
actual cmv number we can get from this
specific sample so so i think um it's
not really we consider as contaminating
it will be more like we consider it as
normal cmv background
thank you
next question what are the lods for cnv
and mutation detection
for ffpe and cfdna can it report by
allelic mutations
okay so
the lod for cmv and mutation
for ffps and cell free dna they are
basically the same
so our panel can adaptive to both sample
types
um
it's similar to what i answered from the
for the previous question so we don't uh
like adjust our panel based on what is
the sample being inputted we just report
what we saw from this sample so the led
will be still the same if you use like a
10 nanogram input of the fft or self
reading example we still can be packed
down to five percent heterozygous single
copy variation or 0.2 percent vf for for
the mutation detection
um for your second question um sorry i
don't have
sufficient knowledge to answer that
right now so i can uh reply to you back
after after this seminar
great well thank you again dr guerrero
de libras dr zhang for your time today
and your important research we would
also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor new probe for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you